2015 saw the return of rock band the  king of rhythm games and if you want  rock band 4 on PC you're going to have  to put your money where your mouth is  developer harmonics is taking the  project to fig the newest and shiniest  crowdfunding site rock band 4 needs two  million dollars to reach the pc but  harmonics is putting in 500,000 of that  themselves that means they're aiming for  one and a half million bucks on fig if  the campaign is successful rock band 4  will launch for PC this fall the new  version will let you create your own  tracks feature we haven't had since the  rock band network shut down two years  ago and every console update will come  to the PC version as well Harmonix  hasn't stayed at any backup plans in  case the campaign fails so if you want  to see rock band 4 on PC it's pretty  much up to you any pledge of at least  forty nine dollars gets you a copy of  the game the campaign ends on april  fifth and we'll have all the results it  came spot at that time